okay at the end here we do a thing
called unhelpful advice with email who
is that Kim Condon's boyfriend yes very
funny yeah
we have emails and they have problems we
give them advice and okay all right a
little agony on session on hope advice
with Michael the champ
Bisby hold on he's stop stop stop was
that your real boys ya know or was that
like some kind of modulator
I don't care your dog died all right
this is entitled losing attraction to
the mother of my kids I'm a 35 year old
Hispanic guy born and raised in East LA
I've been with my girl for over ten
years
and we have three kids our relationship
is good we get along and have fights
like a normal couple she was the first
hip chick I ever dated and I found her
her little quirkiness adorable but over
the years I find something she does very
unattractive she skipped showers for
days all soaps and lotions she uses our
fragrance fragrance free so even when
she does shower I never get that pretty
girl smell sometimes a girl walks by and
I get a tiny whiff of strawberries or a
pretty lotion I really missed that smell
we recently went to a cousin's wedding
and she looked amazing I know with three
kids she doesn't have time to get
dressed up every day she usually doesn't
brush her hair uh it looks like Garth
from the Wayne's World I'm not a big fan
of makeup but a little would help every
now and then lately she won't wear
anything that shows her figure
mostly baggy t-shirts thick denim jeans
now I'm [ __ ] going all-in here yeah
no loser
right now I'm a dude now I'm a dude who
like sex
I still like no with her I still like to
do it I don't like the way you said that
just the way you get that line in a
little different yeah joven your other
voice now I do like sex
they're much better I still like to do
it as often as we can but because of the
shower situation I usually never go down
on I enjoy going down I like the button
all I used to love doing it I told her
in nice ways that these things are
unattractive me but surely this ain't
about doesn't seem to bother her I don't
want to end a relationship with her but
the thought of my life being like this
forever really bums me out any advice
you gave me would be appreciated thank
you guys
first off your guys called sleepers my
guys are called the believers right they
they they do not put in nearly as much
effort into their email just read me a
book a lot of detail fair play to this
guy I mean I really do sympathize with
the situation okay advice I mean you
gotta talk to this lady let's be honest
at the end of the day you gotta pride in
yourself
feels like she's let herself go she's
given up on pride she doesn't see
herself as a sexual being I mean [ __ ]
hygiene and cleanliness come on there's
no excuse for poor hygiene which is what
it sounds like
he's just suffering from ah she's
suffering from so yeah get a [ __ ]
grip
I don't have a word I wonder how much
load she takes on though around the
house that's my question because if
she's doing everything and he's not
helping her along she really might not
have time at all we heard you Rhonda is
out of bed everyday doesn't make hope
she [ __ ] looks beautiful by 7:00 a.m.
every morning you know we don't know
this maybe she fatigues easy I don't
know her situation
yeah blood work done you know he just
needs to sit down and say listen baby
look V lives as a person but you know
when I met you you were this and now you
don't resemble them you know but you got
to pick the words yes me of course you
can't be insulting but it's I think it's
a fair comment to say whatever whatever
a name is yeah you've let yourself go a
little bit you would think that he
probably gave her hints though and I
think that you have to have full
transparency about the copy' birthday
and it's a whole kid of like perfumes
and
like lotions and stuff yeah but hold on
you know what's he look like
what's he probably sitting there
scratching his balls the same shirt he's
that on for [ __ ] days doesn't add a
shower himself he's got his work boots
on
you know he's hammered drunk [ __ ]
[ __ ] did a violin part of miniskirt on
what about him what's he look like
yeah do you know yeah man you're right
she has to say something he's out there
he had to have a talk and or it's for
children but you've got children if they
want to make it work for the kids then
you gotta say listen this is an issue to
me right if it really is an issue which
it sounds like it is then you got to
address it you've gotta at least have
open dialogue and a mature adult
discussion if you deliver it in the
right way and say listen babe yeah I'd
like it if you put a bit of [ __ ]
foundation or maybe had a shower I mean
that's what I don't hear stinky before
he gets into bed I mean sometimes he
comes at me a little bit aggressive
weird and let's wash your [ __ ] feet
because he has foot fungus and brush
your [ __ ] teeth because he has only
two million two teeth left I really the
only gonna treasure them I like 90 but
he doesn't take it you know to heart
he's like okay I got to wash my feet and
do that or else he doesn't get to be
close to me yeah it's just my rules I'm
really really weird about dental hygiene
yes I got an electrical the whole thing
well I bought you that I know that's why
yeah but I do work in progress but you
can't be right about us he has to be
everything you're telling us you have to
tell her nicely mm-hmm yeah for sure you
can say hey you dirty smelly [ __ ] yeah
but it's a mega bar but I know a lot of
girls though in like that won't work
what no the way I said he didn't put a
name but some girls go oh yeah you want
to use natural creams like some girls go
I want to use natural creams I want you
know they get into this bohemian kind of
a thing is that what she's going through
uh kind of like what was she called
Alicia Keys oh yeah no makeup well she's
just beautiful yeah
groans yeah like this foundation I like
a woman to be put together yeah I know
what it may make it effort yeah you know
yeah I quit what not yeah
why the [ __ ] do we have to put it on
every goddamn day for you but I'll spray
it onto you your wife would call you out
problem but that's us oh my ass that you
wash your feet but that's the way it is
you know oh my god you've just hit the
nail on the head this is gonna be the
next movement for women isn't it you
know women empowerment now they don't
wear makeup or [ __ ] put dresses on or
anything we can't do anything men are
inferior
why do you equate wearing natural
products to being unhygenic no no
sometimes natural products is it smell
earthy
like the soil and it's like you know how
like bohemian people like people a woman
that goes to burning match grocer
like your friend Chandi she smells great
hairy pits
yes she does it's like hippie oil yeah I
don't like hippie oil by a woman I like
if you if you put some cool water what's
the old yeah they've reinvented their
thing spice yeah if good uh body wash
anyway um
[Music]